ils ont commencé ce quiz pour faire une
petite compilation de jeux pc il fait
chaud et où j'ai improvisé salle hockey
le premier jeu s'intitule destrac tort
avec du maïs ça fait peur je sais c'est
parti le but de ces drames à saint-max
de maïs pour leur vendre hyper cher sur
les marchés agricoles revoyait des
bruits en fait des heures de tracteur
dans le champ qui rôde et qui veut notre
[ __ ] de mort si on est on est en train
de lui voler son maïs illégalement stade
en forêt je l'entends attends je pars
pars un peu d'un tracteur quand même un
ado elle juste ya un vrai que c'est
l'élan pas que les lectrices
c'est pourquoi un coup franc vite un
couche cours à ok ce que je me mets à
courir vite a battu au moment où j'ai
mis du mail zabana en fait plus j'ai mis
du même hôpital lui qui changent tout le
temps théorique puis j'ai dû mettre sur
moi moi je vais vite voilà t'il et où
ils se rapprochent l'a indiqué l'occ et
attaques furtives du tracteur hu a alors
oui je peux le prendre trois par trois
quoi tu plus efficace que le tracteur
qui pourchassent en fait trop c'est
drôle en [ __ ] il arrive je l'entends
pas mais c'est vrai qu'on ne voit pas
quoi ça fait presque peur moi c'est moi
et ce bar nickel le mec je donne
l'argent ils s'envolent
il use ce [ __ ] tracteur à la fin il
est là à temps mais c'est ça c'est ça
qui est grave c'est ça qui me regardent
et la tronche des trucs il est red eagle
[ __ ] maintenant mais juste envie de
lui faire un cadeau de meaux où le frère
mon fils quoi bon son anniversaire
jackson online la gelée vue à butelle
il a grossi en fait est le papa et le
fiston c'est ça ça c'est le papa à vue
d'oeil qui se déplacent comme ça il
tombe d'un coup quoi on tend non non
donc c'est bon c'est bon tu retournes
maturité dans cette vidéo on est
maintenant sur good wife une bonne femme
en français on avait joué à the good the
band un bon mari il ya très longtemps et
en fait on est juste la femme d'un
monsieur on doit faire des actions pour
qu'ils nous apprécient voilà et ça a
l'air un peu beauf puisque par exemple
mon mari me dit oui mon dîner femmes ou
jeunes accusés c'est ça ohlala on fait
tout pour appeler ça un bon esclaves
quoi il est là ton dîner je l'amène
voilà gros beauf robin omnium dire je
t'aime bof
ah voilà la bière et vous ai je le
savais j'ai été sur le cliché de l'homme
kouao et daimler
bastien touquet à l'ong attend à midi ça
a pris du temps mais mais mais mais déjà
je te donne une bien je te fais à manger
tu fermes ta gueule à temps et si je
donne plein de bière comme ça va être
bourré on va pouvoir aller dans un club
de strip teaser avec les copines tient
du dos c'est drôle ah bon je sais quoi
donner ce qu'un jour je peux vivre
éventuellement non je peux dire que les
deux postes et tâches ménagères
simulator quoi j'adore ce jeu tout ce
que je veux pas faire la maison je suis
obligé de le faire dans jeu en fait
c'est génial à gauche et à coire de quoi
laver des vêtements c'est passionnant
brut moins qu'à l'étagé un spa un truc
pour se détendre l'a pas encore être
aménagées au [ __ ] non mais je sens je
sens la tension cordier toilettes
voilà bravo oh mon dieu you made attend
mais juste mon mari nous c'est une sorte
d'esprit chicchi ans la maison là bas
voilà voilà
c'est le seul moment détente qu'on aura
de l'année en fait un holà trouvera
glock aux habitudes des jeunes m'ont
foutu tu es là bas pendant le beau allez
à bientôt
jn chant prison [ __ ] la foire est pourri
quoi elle dort en prison mais je dois
faire toutes les tâches majeures de la
prison aussi c'est ça la vraie fin le
jeu le plus beau but de l'année elle jeu
suivant ça dégage nous sommes
maintenant sur yang déry simulateur dont
on a vu une image floue la siba je ne
suis pas fou j'ai filé en prison avec la
femme du bo on est donc une écolière
japonaise plutôt mignonne et en fait on
veut séduire un japonais plutôt mignon
on est le lundi 4 avril 2016 ça on s'en
fout là on est dans de petites chambres
d'étudiants et finalement vont au
collège on veut séduire un homme tout ce
que je sais sur ce jeu attend déjà quand
tu vas à l'école c'est rarement comme ça
quoi ya pas de petits arminio ceci
n'existe pas voilà à mon dieu je laime
je suis fou de lui c'est mon nouveau
fond d'écran je sauvegarde et elle veut
quoi la complimente je veux juste te
dire que tu es belle aujourd'hui
regardez on a gagné deux points de
réputation on est des gros fdp on va
essayer d'avoir vraiment une réputation
du feu de dieu et de tous ses buts et un
parc comme des vieilles mères d'art
voulais juste te dire que tu es très
belle aujourd'hui à l'été toi je m'en
fous qui me disent merci plus tard
gilles becker ou qu'on se calme au dos
et quazal carbon des armes quoi alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire faux buts et
les gens c'est ça je peux m'accroupir je
peux me odieux passion c'est ça les
filles je vais te dois complimenter h
peut pas au web aux nouvelles jeunes
relancer le jeu est maintenant les
femmes ont des visages voilà qui parce
qu'avant on était proche du blues band
quand même un don qu'elle a un petit
problème au dos reis et de coupe quand
on dirait qu'il ya deux cornets de glace
à la place de couette
j'ai complément tout ça tout devient mes
copines et ensuite faut que j'aille là
dedans je dois aller en cours j'y vais
de ce pas alors je dois prendre des
trucs et ben physique tout dans le
fuseau donner des bonnes grosses fesses
et dimitri tombe amoureux de nous mais à
bord à laon et après l'école
ok je rentre chez moi kouao la journée
nul l'inde dont je suis amoureux lui va
jamais en cours par contre de la gare
est au pied d'un arbre toute la journée
quoi bats les couilles
yann quéré chan c'est parce qu'on joue
attendait à côté des portes de l'école
que sempai sortent finalement sempai est
sorti le coeur de lion des richesses
battait très fort y adhérer chan a
quitté l'école et regarder sympa est
rentré chez lui une fois sam pas est
rentré chez lui y enterrer chan est
rentrée chez elle elle est allée dormir
et l arrivée lui c'est bon ou pas
attention on est mardi on a jusqu'à
vendredi pour pécho le mec un bon jour
les filles moi ce que je vais pouvoir
but est quelqu'un la souplesse je veux
que ça bute est quelqu'un non mais
comment jambut une [ __ ] tiens je te
pèse non j'ai juste eu quelqu'un bruma
amputations et là encore au ca va
moyenne ça passe oh non non non non non
non non non non non non non non personne
chez ça fera d'ici ça le but personne ne
s'échappera intitulé pas non plus
prostituées tout dans le prospectus qui
est en cause c'est que j'appelle des si
on ne devait pas bien leur est pas bien
du tout on a le coeur qui bat à fond et
tout bah oui on a put être ou alors
acheter les corps un homme et je vais
être 4 en hd tous les corps allaient
tout et tout le sens [ __ ] mais j'ai
tellement de quoi arranger ne me fait
rater les cours c'est obligé
la table sur une absence remarquée à
écouter je nettoyais du saint-georges et
les cada bien un problème biatch au plat
ça dégage
activate ça fait quoi ça c'est les brûle
c'est un trou assez durs des terrains
qui leur a tant je dois attendre autant
de temps mais je n'ai pas du lanceur
s'est rassuré au les attend l afgc
arbres des manières style et qu'on
regardait les 360 avec le ballet plus
efficace que les camions des bois ça ça
fait penser au jeu d'avants mais j'ai
quitté le jeu d'avants pour me retrouve
à refaire du vélo ce [ __ ] j'en ai
marre un voile à l'école est finie tout
un personnage que j'ai buté tout le
monde aurait des cadaves partout mais
que c'est quoi ce délire calais fox
apparaît ses doigts qui est chaude
on s'est mis à la drogue et on a un
petit bidon à l'air quoi je t'aime
sempai je te veux sempai c'est l'heure
de rentrer là y ait trop de rock trop de
centraux demeure tendue les paroles
d'une robe ça une chanson de rap à redon
en mer je crois qu'on s'est fait griller
viande et les chiens ne s'est pas
nettoyé après avoir combien meurtre
at-on bien ce que ces gens les deux
tenues quoi pendant qu'elle marchait aux
alentours de l'école
un enseignant a découvert un corps
sacoche l'enseignant a informé le reste
de la faculté à propos de cette
découverte aux la balance balance et
banon se voisinent les bancs de la fac
tu es se sont mis d'accord pour appeler
la police ait signalé le corps ouais
mais c'est pas moi la police a retrouvé
l'armé du crime mais elles étaient liées
à l'ondé riche en viande et riz chan ne
sera plus jamais capables de confesser
son amour envers sempai bon cette fois
il va en mode efficace et discret jusque
là avec ce chrono rambo par contre
l'idée le mieux c'est que je les buts
ici comme ça ils sont juste à côté de la
machine des trucs pour nettoyer tout va
bien la toute dernière où la butte bon
beach et paris xi fait du patrick
sébastien ne dissuade les gens autour
qui t'ont vu à aller
là c'est la fin des cours la avoir buté
a tourné dans le vide avec n'importe
quoi ce jeu un bon et puis
éventuellement vous voulez bien vous
diriger vers la sortie de la gare ce que
je vous coupe la gorge
non le lendemain bosse bosse bosse
nickel
on est bien on a tous but et on va tout
mettre dans l'accélérateur on met notre
tenue up et on se tire trois potentiels
biatch au moins pour sa part y aller on
est en classe à on s'amuse on apprend
voilà et c'est la fin des cours je vous
emmerde je rentre sur toi sempai un je
t'aime c'est pareil je rentre à la
maison tout ce gros lucas places du cra
au crâne graulhetois places du cra cause
le hazif un kit qu'on l'aura jamais ce n
est pas l amour d'une vie perdue comme
ça je débute tous bien des douze élèves
chaque jour le premier jour ils se
débrouillent manque les trois gains des
élèves où on appelle de nouveau sur
cette question voilà on passe en mode
robben moi c'est quoi ça qui attaquera
qu'un compte du titan hôpitaux katana
mikasa attaque où l'adq ou et la nok
[ __ ] on a été grand pied telle chose
du 128 quoi aussi on l'était en monture
et ses 380 bournoud décor du géant comme
ça sympa il a vu ça ça t'intéresse pas
léger on estime par ailleurs à toi c'est
moi que tu aimes ça part en couille
cette vidéo bon et parfois les gens si
j'attends cette petite compilation de le
voir en vrai c'était neuf dixièmes de
temps sur dix ans des red bull à tort
mais bon j'espère que ça vous a plu si
ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude moi ça m'a plu donc je
vais mais ma propre vidéo est là je suis
un goût une grosse mer dans la vie plus
gros alors c'est une blague passé entre
nous à savoir garder un certain sens
très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
tient du monde portez vous bien un pis